hey guys how's it going welcome back to
my kitchen last week we made peanut
butter jelly sandwiches in the blender
and this week we're going to be making
chocolate chip cookies actually we're
making peanut butter cookies because
there were many chocolate chips what I
do have is six pounds of peanut butter
left let's put that peanut butter to use
so for these cookies we're getting a few
things the recipe calls for some sugar
more sugar baking soda butter chips he
not bought her flour I don't even know
what I'm supposed to start off by doing
I've never made cookies before I've
assisted my mother by watching no
blender today friends one and a half
cups of all-purpose flour you are a cup
move you out of the way I want to use my
blender into the bowl small 1/2 teaspoon
of baking soda well I don't have a
teaspoon so let's just looks like a
teaspoon is my blender one cup not gonna
screw this up again what is one sick of
you I think I used two of these let's
just put you in here how soft does this
have to be Oh No okay let's put you in
the microwave let's put all the
ingredients in shall we I wish this was
printed hey peanut butter great sugar of
God half cup sure this ba half cup looks
good to me
look I ain't about that measuring life
so let's just what looks like a teaspoon
I like been on right yeah that's great
piece this up this all I have to do I
just mix this in this as a cookie I put
my egg in oh my god talk about luck I
have one single egg left oh look at you
somebody told me the other day that an
egg is a chicken's period and since I've
heard that I've not been able to get
that image from my mind think about it
combine flour well it just gradually
beaten flour mixture I'm going to make
this work and it's going to be the best
cookies anybody has ever tasted and you
know what we're gonna do we're going to
add a little extra peanut butter mix
this up you know I do this in such a
wrong order is
even the right thing that I should be
using to mix this with skeet ball mixing
that see me mix and something is not
right like what in this haze right I
just pour them all in it'll be great
this is so are you mix okay I'm over
this
let's put this on a pan Oh on greased
baking sheet is this a baking sheet I
think I should grease it right in there
no skip skip skip skip skip scoop you
look so good I can't wait to eat you I
don't know what's gonna happen I should
smash you down nice chicken fingers what
are you I don't know is it a cookie is
it a cake this is we have so far it's
our cookie or a cake I don't know what
you guys think it is is it a cookie or
is it a cake the oven is now preheating
and a few minutes I'll place this into
the oven to prepare for it some estimize
do your thing
well that's the block all right so I
think we may have a little bit of
problem I think I might have put a
little too much peanut butter in because
every time I check this thing it's
really soft
hi yes Ryan is this gonna harden do you
think yeah my cell cookies too much cuz
with the middle is gonna be cookie like
yo cookie dough kind of flavor you know
no I don't oh yeah you're good you can
tell the chef is around here yeah
sometimes I make a little cookie let's
just cut this right down the middle
mmm well crispy on the bottom if you
hold Ellie in there
oh my tell me what you think about it
look good cosmic plating is not good ha
ha how's a big bite all right Billy I
hate Sam
my name's what stand in here how's good
if you have any more left
oh all right well I think I put your
game Arabians
well I didn't measure any of them that's
obvious for sure thank you guys for
watching leave me a comment below and
let me know what you think I should make
next so do you think I should make next
stuffed french toast I want to make a
pie pie some heart you know goalies
you're judging me yeah I see judging
eyes all right guys see you later